[Musique]
comme au lycée je n'arrivais pas rentrer
dans le vif du sujet aujourd'hui je vais
vous parler d'une émission de télé je
vais pas faire le mytho je ne
connaissais pas cette émission avant
hier c'est une vieille émission qui date
des années 2000 je crois que c'était
diffusé genres entre 2003 et 2007 c'est
l'oreille qui m'a envoyé ça et je suis
abattu de découvrir ça seulement
maintenant parce que c'est hilarant
peut-être certains d'entre vous la
connaissent attention ça s'appelle peur
surprise je comprends pas d'ailleurs
pourquoi surprise ils ont pas mis le
mois on attachait calais le jeu de mot
ça mélange tout ce qu'on aime les prend
qu on adore tous et surtout le délire de
l'horreur des trucs bien bas dans bien
flippant comme les threads que vous
adorez sur cette chaîne le concept est
hyper simple il ya des gens qui veulent
piéger un proche à eux ils font appel à
l'équipe de télévision en leur disant
mon meilleur ami n'est pas trop les
arédiens est il cet homme un piège
affreux avec genre d araignée et
franchement c'est incroyable les idées
que les gars ruelles sont hyper bonne et
je suis complètement passé à côté j'ai
le sommes
j'ai maté un seul épisode qu'on va pas
regarder en sommes aujourd'hui là on va
juste découvrir les autres sans y en a
qui ont l'air incroyable c'est parti oui
ça me plaît déjà dsk bienvenue dans peur
surprise hier l'émission qui plonge les
gens dans des situations terrifiantes
déjà j'entends une voix off comme ça
j'ai l'impression d'être en 2011 devant
game one et des reportages
ça me fait bizarre jean paul a trouvé un
petit boulot dans le bâtiment pour son
pote bryant est sympa jean paul on veut
tous un jean-paul autour de nous ryan
est venu jeter un oeil au terrain mais
c'est du ciel que va venir la menace
c'est ce que vous faites
brian la victime
j'aimerais pas habiter là dedans non
plus là c'est bondé bel et bien dans les
scènes d'été
[Musique]
c'est quoi ça alors les effets les ont
rajouté en post production mais ils ont
pour de vrai fait bouger la caravane
d'un coup comme ça qu'est-ce qui se
passe vachon ya un truc qui est tombé du
ciel
c'est une météorite s'est tu délires
qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'est tout il
a juste dit waouh c'est délirant mes
parents courant appelle la police vers
trucage i oi t'as vu ce bloc là dans la
vache ses gaffes mec ça chauffe
ouais bien on vend
tu n'a touché à 1 ça fait mal ce truc
assieds toi je vais me passer de l'eau
dessus
hopla psy grattage de top on a failli
crever à ce raid est réalisé il réalise
us très en retard au terme que se
passe-t-il c'est les men in black
bonsoir agents perkins et stuart qu'est
ce qui s'est passé ils sont allés loin
ils ont ramené des faux men in black
qu'est ce que j'aimerais bien j'ai un
pote avec autant moyens vous avez touché
la météorite n'ont jamais lot de galères
pour que j'aille à l'oustau monsieur
avez-vous touché cet homme non oh le bon
replay il fait plaisir mais attend lui
il est en train de complètement se
désolidariser c'est terrible il va tout
balance directives à calais rebondir il
a même mangé de la météorite vous
devriez vraiment l'emmener pour lui se
sortir d'affaires mais qu'est ce qui
m'arrive
vous avez touché un objet radioactifs
c'est ce qui explique ce malaise
passager attend tu vois des cas les
tâches est de 10 cm vers le côté opposé
à ton ami quitte à troubat au travail
qui plus est pas très sympa qu'est ce
que c'est
asseyez-vous sûrement pas jointes debout
c'est quoi la chute je me demande est ce
qu'ils ont trouvé avant de faire des
dons perçus venez on va vous emmener à
l'hôpital
une équipe de secours arrivent dans 5
minutes d'accord ok
[Musique]
tout va bien elle est mort c'est ça on
veut tous un jean-paul mais aucun ne
veut un brian c'est pas possible
et les morts c'est bon le problème est
terminée je peux rentrer chez moi gros
un effort un peu de compassion je sais
pas il a trébuché sur une météorite et
les men in black lui bruit des balles
dans le dos la t100 c'est vraiment être
choqué vous avez m'abattre mois ci
devront neutraliser le danger mais si je
peux voir au badge à aillas le petit
doute de la france crève mais la preuve
qu'il ya des gros moyens ils ont fait
faire des faux badges chez nous sommes
les agents d'une émission de caméra
cachée encore surprise j'adore et niveau
est d'ampleur surpris cette image et
adore il est mignon fait brian bon là on
est vraiment dans ce genre la science
fiction c'est même pas de l'aura c'est
de la science fiction les prochaines
c'est un peu plus bas dans puisque c'est
du bréau voir comme on le connaît c'est
une bonne mise en bouche quand on prends
une babysitter on veut avoir l'esprit
tranquille tu h l'égard des enfants
depuis des années et elle a été
chaudement recommandé par son ami
félicia type fokker mais la petite anna
mais toujours ses baby sitter à rude
épreuve à a pas mal point qu'elle baby
sitter en fait c'est beaucoup plus
simple puisqu'elle vient dans une maison
et ajusta avoir toussé top dans la
maison fin c'est assez c'est pas mal
attend l'enfant l'enfant il va être méga
badens je te présente ashley ça va
ouf je joue avec quoi je vais y aller et
vous laisser toutes les deux quelle
bonne idée
ma fille vient d'envoyer chier la baby
sitter mais plutôt que la remettre à sa
place je vais y aller et les laisser
toutes les deux que faites vous là
non non non non
qu est ce qu ils font quoi à temps elle
va faire genre du désert
anna et comment
à il ya quelqu'un d'autre qui va arriver
dans ce déguisement et sauf que cette
fois quand l'hôtel va faire anna bon
c'est bolton
j'avais dans ma chambre si c'est ça
c'est trop bien d'accord moi c'est ça
c'est sûr c'est sûr ça
arrête 20 dans ta chambre
quoiqu'il y a quelqu'un dehors c'est qui
ça oh là là tu m'as pris mon job qui
nous attend mais un mec vient de buter
une fenêtre à la hachette et ashley elle
garde son pied posé sur la table basse
comme quand tu regardes netflix quoi
elle est un niveau de chill quai sans
précédent quoi tu as peur oui j'ai peur
tu ne devrais pas fait tant peur
surprise s'est félicité à piéger
c'était horrible quand il est entré je
savais plus du tout quoi faire pas mal
je ne suis pas déçu ok est fasciné par
le surnaturel et sa femme mira et son
ami marc elles ont décidé qu'il était
temps de le ramener à la réalité
bonjour ça lui a bien dit il
je vais kéké
je suis quelqu'un est géniale qui était
seul à bord vraiment tu as eue j'entends
des choses
mickael ma grand mère dit que j'ai un
dante voiture quel endroit voiture mais
attends mais qu était incroyable moi un
enfant me dit ça je lui dis bah c'est
simple tu changes de restaurants
maintenant tu t'en vas tu me laisses en
terrasse tranquille et tu te casses
texas
je suis du texas t'assure salle amuse
beaucoup trop par rapport à la gravité
de la situation
après havre et s'il n'y croyais qu'il
est passionné là ils croient enfin
tomber sur quelqu'un qui parlait que les
morts du coup il est refaite et envoie
sa chérie et en australie et l
t'appelles tu as low as a pas mal ça
ouah mira tu vas pas me croire
moi qui ai marre qu'elle était aux
toilettes il a tout raté vient de
refaire c'est génial comment il osera me
kiffe et nous tous les humains ça nous
ferait méga bad et tu vois qui se passe
à l'huile en train de kif et il est
vraiment heureux de ce qui vient de se
passer c'est génial voilà
il la rappelle il prend tellement 2 il
la rappelle j'ai rarement vu à une prog
où le gars prend autant de plusieurs
sites web tu dois savoir quoi ne rentre
pas chez toi ce soir je ne rentre pas
chez moi
il va y avoir un feu dans la cuisine ou
qui devrait sortir peu peur de là
[Musique]
j'y crois pas aulas ok j'ai capté c'est
là qu'il apprend que commence anna que
fais tu la sens tu attends tous dans le
fourgon
c'est génial quelle bonne idée regardez
bien comme l'expression du visage de
keke a drastiquement changé depuis qu'il
a découvert qu'elle parle en langage des
ces essais elle vous embêtait non non
pas du tout si ça lui arrive de fixer
les gens qu'elle ne peut pas vraiment
communiqué whissell ne parle pas non non
elle n'a jamais parlé elle est sourde de
naissance aulas social national de keke
c'est génial parce qu'ils pensent être
au avoir genre une petite voyante devant
lui cadet des pouvoirs surnaturels qui
est capable de lui dire le jour et
l'heure de sa mort s'il sera riche ou
pas je sais pas et là d'un coup pour lui
ça devient une petite fille très creepy
très dangereuse elle parlait voilà ça
peut vous paraître bizarre cet enfant un
don à ils y croient trop s'il est
vraiment fan de ça en fait c'est trop
mignon
elle est sourde écoutez écoutez cet
enfant indien et vous savez quoi
et c'est pas drôle
c'est pas drôle d'accord très bien alors
voir où ça chauffe là il est quand même
cool moi si ça m'arrive jamais de la vie
je vais dire un mot de ce qui s'est
passé à la maman je vais la laisser avec
son enfant maudit là il va leur arriver
des trucs bizarres mais ce sera sans moi
elle revient à une nouvelle et bonne
twitch haut dans cette vidéo je me
refais mai et mode pitch [ __ ] quel
plaisir à n'a ni l'heure mais non c'est
aux rimes refait le jury dans père
surpris que vous m'avez bien itoïz mec a
un point ces genres honteux en 2020 gens
c'est sûr ça marche pas le délire la
caméra cachée de la preuve qui s'est
trop répandue mais à cette époque là
franchement si j'avais été kg aurait cru
mille fois j'aurai fini en émaux twitch
mais directement au maire
est-ce qu'on a une haute ou pas le pp
sitting est un bon moyen de se faire un
peu d'argent mais c'est aussi une bonne
occasion d'utiliser la petite anna pour
flanquer la frousse au chan ok nouvelles
prend canton de st gall sont faciles à
ces tops celle là je comprends pourquoi
il en abuse and à saly sénégal sames ami
nous a quittés récemment et elle est un
peu sauvage ces temps ci c'est le même
héros c'est qu'on parle à sa mamie en
fait mais il ne faut pas vous en faire
c'est juste qu'elle aime jouer ici
c'était la chambre de sa mamie zaw oo
qu'est ce que je fous là
tu veux jouer avec moi mais celle là tu
veux que je la porte oui tu seras belle
mais ça la mamie les portes est tout le
temps alors déjà dont et ensuite on va
les brûler directement hockey à elle est
mal à l'aise elle est pas l ami chip
fracking polyglotte est mignonne mais
maintenant tu vas arrêter de m'habiller
comme ta grand mère tout de suite je ne
suis pas ta grand mère c'est bon elle
est morte et une changera rien arrête de
pleurer je serai un affreux baby sitter
je comprends pourquoi j'ai jamais fait
enfin je comprends pourquoi aucun parent
ne m'a jamais assez fait confiance c'est
tellement glow moi j'aurais jamais
accepté joli collier
la langue vient de bouger oups puristes
mais mam il avait tout le temps de
bouger
ok c'est pour la chute du prof mais
c'est tout le match comme suit en vrai
d'époque en est érodée malade qu'on
faisait des proc
[Musique]
la sortir oui
non là non la non tu peux pas continuer
d'y croire c'est évident là on devrait
aller dehors comme ami tu nous fait peur
aux c'est horrible
[Musique]
à hull city
je devrais pas évident par surprise
mon amie sonia fait passer à la télé pas
mal tout est franchement pas mal quand
même
mais le truc de la grand mère moi
j'aurais explosé la porte s'est ouverte
sur une vue la grand-mère j'aurais fait
eh bien écoutez c'est la fin de peur
surprise j'espère que ça vous a pu jouer
trop parler de cette émission c'est sûr
mais en fait j'aimerais trop me faire
prendre comme ça mais je crois que je
découvrirai en deux secondes que c'est
une preuve tu tellement cartésien et
tous que ça marchera pas quoi genre
deuxième objet qui bouge je vais aller
l'apprend cas cassez vous c'est un peu
fini l'âge d'or des prendre parce que
maintenant tout le monde sait que ça
existe et du coup tout le monde est
méfiant d'équipier un truc un peu
bizarre un peu abusé ses premiers
réflexes tu vois c'est une caméra cachée
des fois même tu le dis alors qu'ils
évitent bien vraiment arrivé un truc pas
aux tellement c'est dans l'inconscient
il ya plein d'épisodes jeu du boyau
nexon h hier je vais pas vous mentir une
réaction rend pas mal donc voilà si vous
faire plaisir et c'était pas à mater ça
ça me fait marrer moi j'ai un petit
monde un peu vieille émission tv clabaut
fait tout je sais pas j'ai un petit côté
nostalgique là ça me fait marrer je vous
dis à bientôt
vous étiez dans
[Musique]